[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
happy holidays and happy week 16
everybody hope you all had a great
christmas and have a great new year you
just tapped in to the br betting squad
ride live in the bleacher report app
presented by draftkings i'm connor
rogers alongside the only man more
giving than santa claus greg ivory how
we doing how we feeling how we living
doing good feeling great living better
but
connor i'm living so good and i'm
feeling so good and it's christmas
you know the day after christmas santa
claus came yesterday but guess what greg
claus is here today and i'm giving away
some hoodies
connor uh if you guys at home don't know
now i'm gonna teach you guys something
this right here is the handy dandy ipod
and this is how
you get your hoodies i got jason key for
11. jason kiefer 11 is in the comments
saying
joe mixon will score a touchdown today
appreciate you jason for your comment
uh you're walking away with a hoodie
connor
let's get this thing going man
let's get right into it you know the
deal by now this is the show where we
are looking for the locks of the week to
score a touchdown who is getting in the
end zone we ask you on social we ask you
in that bleacher report app in the vr
betting community stream who's it gonna
be who's a lot to score let's take a
look at the most popular picks we were
sent this week with the featured odds
board at the top there corduro patterson
been a stud all year long the biggest
surprise said cooper cup the number one
ranked player in ppr fantasy my goodness
what a year for him ronald jones taking
over for leonard fournette josh jacobs
keenan allen might see a lot of targets
today greg mike williams going on the
covet list more targets for keenan allen
tyler lockett a disappointing run here
for saquon barclay can he finish the
year strong and josh allen at the bottom
of the board but still plus 180 taking
on those patriots so we got a lot to get
through today greg tell them what you
got on tap to give away
connor i'm not only giving away hoodies
but i'm giving away two not one but two
nfl jerseys of your choice one to the
lucky
lock legend winner of the tournament and
one to a lucky commenter like yourself
so stick around
chill out with me and connor here's some
winners you guys also comment some
winners you might be walking out of here
with the jersey uh i need emojis i need
gifts but most importantly you guys can
type this out as i say it i need winners
only please connor i think they get the
memo by now they get the memo by now and
that's what we find on this show and we
need to find that for week 16 the squad
ride leader the squad ride title let's
get right into it greg round number one
the first submission is from p mcquade
18. let's see what you got this week p
mcquade
let's see what the lock cookers got in
for this week
saying cam newton anytime touchdown
square for this week but lock it in
cooking up locks going with cam newton
going to be an interesting week for
those panthers as they activate sam
darnold expected to play a lot we'll get
that into that in a little bit here greg
well let's see the first challenger of
the week here and it's a familiar face
you know him by now w trammell what
holidays holiday stuff you got cooking
up here for this week
what's up vr nation we're back with baby
time touchdown twinkle's wood let's see
if it'll give us one last christmas skit
stefan dudes
the plank aboard is back going with
stephon diggs plus 150. we got a tight
one here greg plus 140 for cam plus 150
for diggs
let him know what we need to decide this
round one and i want to know which way
you're going with this matchup
what i need you guys to do what i need
you guys to do is get in the comments
and let me know if you are rocking with
cam newton
or are you rocking with stefan diggs uh
connor cam
i mean there's been speculations i just
got the i just got the
the bleach report alert saying that sam
darnold might be playing today
i mean i know when the panthers get in
the gold line i know what they're
they're gonna do
i think you know what they're gonna do a
heavy dose of cam but i i i just i don't
know if i'm willing to put my money on
that but and then let's talk about
stefan diggs he had a
game but he did score a touchdown last
week he did score a touchdown last week
but we know josh allen loves to find
stephon diggs connor he loves to find
stefan diggs
he's a target monster like you say uh i
think i want to lean stefan diggs here
which way are you leading
i'm with you all the way man i mean when
you look at this just how do you trust
the panthers right now i mean you got to
ask sam darnold in between the 20s to
get down into the red area and then
maybe cam comes on the field so that's
not even in cam's hands and i don't
trust sam darnold to do that right now
and everybody's got this big fear about
the number one wide receiver who takes
on the patriots every week because
that's who belichick takes away i think
everybody's forgetting how different the
staffon digs josh allen connection can
be and if the bills are gonna be in that
game if they're gonna win that game and
try to make a run into the playoffs or
take back that division whatever it may
be they need stefan diggs to get going
they are not just going to wipe him out
of the playbook out of the game plan so
i'm not afraid of staphon digs i love
the plus 150 i like it better than cam
i'm with you greg i'm rolling with diggs
but we gotta decide this for the
comments where are they going right now
uh let me hop back into my handy daddy
ipad and give away some hoodies i got
evmula evan says diggs is a winner shout
out to you ev you were walking away with
a hoodie uh
i also got
i got steve my boy matt dodger says
diggs is a brainerd thank you steve uh
here we go
i got
one more one more one more i see
carlos
i need diggs to score to win this week
too so he's rocking with stephon dix
shout out to you carlos everybody that i
mentioned and his his username is loso90
that is for the producers everybody that
i mentioned you all are walking away
with a hoodie connor i think i'm gonna
make the
the decision here we are riding with
stefan diggs moving on to the next round
so uh shout out to the plinko legend man
we're moving on to the next round the
the plinko legend do not doubt the
plinko all right round number two ryan
schroeder getting in the mix here i
heard it's a little bit of cowboys
nation uh getting involved here which
was a big winner for us last week let's
see what ryan just a little bit for us
[Music]
shout out be our betty getting ready for
any time to touchdown store lock of the
week
[Applause]
feed them greg you know what it is by
now ezekiel elliott he's been a squad
ride winner before and cashed in pretty
big for everybody that trails the squad
ride so we like that we like that one a
lot taking on stephon diggs
where are we going is this enough greg
is this enough in round two to knock off
digs and we like those running backs
they're a little bit more safe is this
enough here to run it back with zeke of
this for the second week in a row
this one's tough connor i'll be honest
this one's tough taking on washington
today taking on watching division match
up this one's gonna be tough but i do
think i do think z can't get in the end
zone he faced washington two weeks ago
he did not get in he did not get a
rushing touchdown but
this week i don't know connor it's just
something in the atmosphere something in
the vibe saying that zeke's gonna get a
rushing touchdown this week he had one
last week went for 16 for 52 i could see
zeke
getting in the end zone that offense
conor let's talk about the offense amari
cooper just said that he felt like his
role uh he needed a bigger role that
offense they have a lot of weapons they
have a lot of weapons
but they flow they flow when they run
the ball they flow when they run the
ball so
i can see my guy zeke getting in but i
still like stefan diggs i i want to lean
stefan diggs and you guys see the odds
right there do not be alarmed you guys
know what we can do to the eyes here on
the squad ride i want to lean stefan
diggs but i also like zeke i'm torn
connor which way are you riding
right yeah i'm not like overly jacked up
about either of these you said it greg
they got so many mouths to feed in that
dallas offense we loved what zeke did
for us last week and there's a reason
zeke's a favorite on this show but it's
pretty obvious that they know they need
to get that pass game going the
washington secondary does not scare you
at all so i think they're going to try
to make everybody happy from michael
gallup to cd lamb to amari cooper of
course in that pass game but
when they get down to the goal line
there's an easy answer for them it's
zeke all day but i'm not afraid of digs
like i said so i'm good with either one
of these i'm curious to see what round
three brings us uh where are the
comments pushing us as this is a little
bit of a toss up here
i'm in the handy dandy this one this one
is a toss-up this one is a toss-up
i have uh
connor connor cl43 that's not you in the
comments is it connor no
no that's your burner in the comments
well anyway this carter in the comments
why i'm pushing this one way or the
other
this connor in the comments is rocking
with stefan diggs shout out to you
connor you were walking away with a
hoodie i got lee ross garza lee rose
guards that says zeke
what the lock emoji shout out to julie
rose you are walking away with the
hoodie uh ashley's in the comments what
up ashley ashley guerrero says zeke
because he's on my fantasy team well
guess what ashley you were walking away
with the hoodie uh
i i guess oh my boy jesse24 is in the
comments says bang bang and he gave us a
zeke emoji connor
i guess i gotta make the call man i
gotta make the call as much as i wanna
say stefan diggs
we are rocking with ezekiel elliott
moving on to the next round connor
and greg like you've said before if it's
not broken don't fix it so we're rolling
with zeke again yeah if it's enough yes
yeah you know what it is you know what
it is so all right round three
let's see if it's enough for zeke to
take back to back weeks i don't think
we've had that on this show yet so that
would be a little bit of a stunner all
right the next one from it's antonio 12.
let's see that selection and let's see
if it's enough to knock off a favorite
in ezekiel elliott
corduro patterson the guy that came in
at the top of the board this week the
stocking legend find the locks and i
didn't get any locks in my stocking so a
good job there by dad apparently
man two running backs two workhorses
they both get the carries they both get
the targets especially cp they are
playing that sorry lions defense i don't
know greg this might be the one yes
where are you going and or i think we're
going to lean on the comments a little
bit but i want to know where you're
going here
i'm i'm i'm honestly torn connor i'm
honestly torn we just talked about zeke
and his impact on that dallas offense
but let's talk about cordell patterson i
mean my guy he's he got his little debo
debo samuels impression i mean he's
running the ball catching the ball
lining up that wide receiver lining up
in the backfield so he can score in
multiple ways i can see why he's minus
165 and we're talking about this lions
deep the lions defense the lions defense
that's been the same defense this whole
year but i'll hold off on that i'll hold
off on that lions defense but uh i'm
honestly torn i'm torn i am torn
on this connor i'm gonna lean on the
audience here which way are you riding
let's have some fun let's give him a
christmas gift let's give him a little
holiday spirit here let's let him choose
you and i we we guide this one way or
the other week after week we beg
sometimes we demand i just lean on him
greg get the handy dandy out let him go
let him make this choice and i'll bet on
it i don't care
this right here is the handy danny to
the new people on the show and i am in
the comments and we're going to see who
we are riding with uh binium binyamin
binyamin ben the goat 123 says patterson
is due 100 he did get clamped up by the
nyers last week
as expected uh
but he's due this week uh i got ryan
ryan says ryan the panda says patterson
two touchdowns this week connor not one
but to uh shane the life of smitty the
life of smitty says patterson is a lock
uh
and then i got justin potter
justinpotter24 says cornell patterson
says if my mom worked three jobs why
can't i play three positions i love that
mindset conor it appears the people have
spoken
we are
riding with core dale patterson
to score a touchdown
today
let's pull up the graphics so i can show
you guys what we can do here on the
squat
ride uh you guys see cordell patterson
-165 let me show you guys some magic
poof just like that
it went up to plus 110 shout out to our
friends at draftkings for boosting that
up from minus 165 to plus 110 check out
br betting socials for a link to the
odds boost send us your screenshots of
your bets send us your videos
and your celebrations but most
importantly connor and you guys can type
this out as i say it we want winners
only please
110. i think everybody's got to be a
little happy with that cp's due for a
big bounce back week we are not done
greg is not done being generous he
boosted cp we got a squad ride leader
and it's antonio but we got locks to
give out we got hoodies greg's still got
another nfl jersey we're not done let's
get right into it sir 30 comment contest
time we asked you this week in the app
in social not a fun topic but we got to
know it's a safe space let it out what
were your worst savings
2021.
greg and they're comfortable telling you
what did they send you what are the
worst beats
hey guys this is a safe space i love
that connor you guys could tell us
whatever take you guys have that is on
your mind drop it in the comments this
is a safe space but let's start off
let's start off with connor
wait is this your burner account again
bro connor not a pka97
connor pka 97 says last week took the
same game parlay with the 49ers money
line debo over 29 and a half receiving
yards debo over 29 and a half rushing
yards and the last play of the last
drive
he ran the ball for two yards to end
with 29 rushing yards wow
connor i don't know if this is you on
your burner or if this is actually a
connor out there but they got burned by
the hook man
greg if this happened to me i wouldn't
have showed up for today's show uh
there's a story there for to connor
nation right now we're struggling we're
hurting and devo just had a monster week
a couple days after this so you
should've ran it back i'm sorry my
fellow connor i don't know if it gets
worse than that we're about to find out
because we got one more right
yes we definitely do got one more uh we
got kai ka t 96 says
12 leg parlay free 25 to 140 k
last leg only needed steelers minus four
and a half
week six against seattle they won by
three
couldn't cash out
because of the free bet you should have
hedged bro you gotta hedge in this
situation
we
we've been here before we've been i went
i flew out to vegas connor and i met up
with uh i think his name is uh i think
his name was troy i met up with no tony
i'm sorry tony my man tony met up with
tony in vegas my man had this big parlay
you know we were riding with him br
bedding was there
but he did not hedge
any longer and we learned from that we
learned he lost yeah he lost we learn
from that we learn from our mistakes my
god when you're in this situation you
got to hedge connor talk to him man
listen to greg greg knows he's witnessed
it firsthand he's witnessed the
heartbreak for vr vetting way too many
times you've got to hedge and if you
really
really either you don't know the cash
the head you don't want it whatever it
is do not use your free bets on 12 leg
parlays you're not
all smooth you're just trying to play
the cash you have to turn 25 bucks into
a grand 5 grand 10 grand 15. you're not
the chances of hitting that 40 uh it's
too slim so i'm i'm sorry i feel bad
this happened to you keith maybe i think
greg's going to have to make it up to
you i don't know what maybe
he's the pain
might got to make it up to him let me
check out the comments though let me
check out the comments see what they're
talking about uh br betting is in the
comments not being able to cash out
equals paying yes that is pain uh
real buddha53 says winner's only please
most people cannot hedge 40k a 400 for
yeah 40k that that that is a fair point
i i agree with that uh then hedge what
you can call your friends heads what you
can call your call a friend yeah exactly
call connor no i'm just kidding but yeah
wait call call your friends
call your friends
ross
ross uh larosa's back into the comments
saying i like that they like that
uh locks underwater is in the comments
saying winners only please shout out to
you locks underwater you were walking
away with the hoodie everybody i
mentioned you guys are walking around
hoodie connier i'ma make a decision here
my guy keith we still got him up on the
board or he still he was up on the
screen not too long ago and i felt bad
for him
because uh he was close to 40k so
i'm gonna send you
a hoodie and a jersey hopefully that can
make you feel better uh but next time
next time next time please head
greg doing it right though hoodie and a
jersey to keith i mean good lord that
that's a rough loss it's the least we
could do uh shout out to greg for
hooking it up he's got a big heart all
right time for prop lock or drop it prop
segment time i mean come on this is what
we do by now you either lock the prop or
you want nothing to do with it and i
like what we got in store this week tell
them what the first one is uh because
this one this is a fun one right here
i got you connor but before i tell you
guys make sure you guys get in the
comments and let us know if you guys are
locking it in or if you guys are
dropping it uh let's get right into it
connor uh
josh out
josh allen to throw for two or more
touchdowns just need two touchdowns to
hit a hundred in his career he only
threw for one touchdown in the last
meeting against the patriots
and
connor the bills only scored 10 points
in that last matchup
do you like my guy josh allen to throw
for two or more touchdowns today
all right greg
i'm gonna give you the bad news talk to
me
the bad news first is they're playing
the hoodie they're playing new england
that defense
is nasty they're well coached they take
away
whatever you like best which means
stefan diggs
it's gonna be it might be a long day
the good news is greg your guy josh
allen has done this 11 times this year
11 times basically it's an outlier for
him to not throw two touchdowns so
with that being said
don't be afraid of the patriots here
that bill's gotta get back up their
momentum they gotta show that they're
not pushed around in this division they
gotta show that this is just as much
their afc east as its new englands in
this new era without tom brady i like it
gray i usually don't like these
offensive props i'm locking it josh
allen thrown for two touchdowns what
about you
i i like it too i like it too
the last i i just want to talk about the
bills running the ball josh allen had
the most rushing yards for them last
week he ran for 109.
running backs ran the ball a total of
seven times last week connor they ran
the ball seven times last week josh
allen he threw the ball 54 times last
week so just do the math let's just do
the math here let's just do the math the
bills they haven't been running the ball
devin singletary been out there zach
moss been out there matt breed have been
up they just have not been they don't
have an identity to run the ball but
guess what they do have an identity to
do
throw the ball so josh allen getting two
tds today i like my chances he's going
to be throwing the ball connor i mean
last time they played this new england
team the weather was an issue today the
weather is going to be a little bit
better so give me josh allen throwing
two touchdowns today lock that one in
i like it dude i love that one i think
people i like the new england beer
that's what the sports books telling you
don't be afraid all right keep it moving
what else we got
let's go to your boy your boy connor
cooper cup cooper cup to have over 106
and a half receiving yards
he's has had 10 consecutive games with
more than 90 receiving yards this is the
longest streak in nfl
history connor do you think
this is a lock do you like this or are
you dropping this one
i love it listen i usually don't like
the overs when the total is high or even
mediocre cooper cup though greg i know
you're going to get into it in a little
bit he's a lock for these kinds of games
he's the king of 100 yard receiving
games this year so
and the matchup's great against
minnesota there's nothing that scares
you here he's a target monster he's the
go-to guy the defense he's playing in
minnesota does not put a lot of fear
into you stopping him or taking him away
man i look at cooper cup who like i said
is the number one ppr fantasy player
this year and this is i can't believe
this isn't 120 130 something to scare to
her people from betting on this one
let's go man where are you with this
connor let me let me let me read off
some numbers to you and i'll let you
take a guess on what i'm reading off 136
123 129
96 122 95 115 156 130 i can keep going
bro i i can't do it my guy cooper my guy
exactly exactly he's been putting up
yards this year he's been putting up
numbers and i said a lot of hundreds i i
i set a lot of hundreds just in that
those like
seven games that i just went through uh
i like this a lot conor i like this a
lot that minnesota vikings defense that
doesn't
they don't scare me i'm pretty sure they
don't scare the rams uh matt stafford's
gonna do what he do drop back if he
doesn't see odell he's gonna go to his
comfort blanket cooper cup he's been
doing it all year i don't if it ain't
broke don't fix it i'm riding with
cooper cup to go over 106.5
yards today it's it's as simple as that
let me see what they're talking about in
the comments though connor
let me see what they're talking about in
the comments uh yep they're riding what
a spin spin uh spin co says cooper cup
he gave us some trophy emojis real
buddha 53 says it is a lock he gave us a
cooper cup gift giving a thumbs up shout
out to you
uh
jj snell wow jj snell was throwing a
little bit of bad vods into the comments
he gave us a thumbs down but guess what
jj snail i'm gonna wake your game up and
i'm gonna brighten your day and i'm
gonna send you a hoodie i'ma sing you a
hoodie just to brighten your day man uh
but cooper cup i think that's a lot
connor
yeah me too unfortunately i'm seeing him
in the uh semi-finals of the playoffs
here greg so i'm a little nervous but i
think cooper cup is a lot of time
weekend all right maybe something to
brighten it up though it's time before
we get out of here you and i do our
boldest bets basically me and greg are
going to drop our most far-fetched bets
of the week we want to know who you're
riding with who are you rolling with who
greg's going to give away hoodies at the
end before we get out of here so
greg
how are we feeling about our burst bets
this week we've been uh we've been a
little up and down up and down but
that's why they're both they're not baby
bad so let's have some fun with it right
yes these are boldest bets for a reason
they're both bets for a reason feeling
good connor feeling feeling good uh i
need you guys to get in the comments and
let me know if you are riding
with me or if you're riding with connor
uh just let me know but connor let's
just get right to it bro let's just get
right to it tell them what you got
i don't even know what i'm thinking with
this one i'm just gonna have some fun
with it it's been a miserable rookie
year for trevor lawrence right now and
i'm betting on him to get in the end
zone with his legs this week against the
jets run defense that can't stop anyone
i think with no urban there
they got to be open-minded to getting
back to something trevor was really good
at at clemson and that's making plays
with his legs that big frame he can get
in and bully defenders at the goal line
i like trevor lawrence to score a
touchdown whether it's a quarterback
sneak quarterback draw breed option they
gotta get him moving in the red zone to
do something different with this offense
now early in the season he did this
twice he did it in back-to-back weeks
they've gotten away from it for the
better part of two months now so trevor
lawrence get him comfortable get some
points the jets run defense doesn't stop
anybody this is a good opportunity plus
450 is the real reason we're here greg
okay
i like that connor i like that i like
that uh let me go to atlanta let me go
to atlanta that is the hometown of our
director here uh and the atlanta falcons
is taking on
the detroit lions the detroit lions
and uh atlanta they lost two of their
last three and guess what connor the
lions they have won two of their last
three
the lions they play hard they've been
playing hard although their record is
what it is they play hard they play hard
for dan campbell
and i think that they're going to play
hard tonight i think they're going to
play hard today actually against this
atlanta focus team they don't scare
anybody this atlanta falcons team
they've been up and down up and down
i can see them getting upset by this
detroit lions team and if the lions win
it has to at least be by field goal but
who knows conor they might blow them out
today so i'm taking the minus three
sitting that plus 325.
y'all let me know in the comments if
y'all like this or not man but this is
what we rock it with
greg's feeling the good detroit vibes
there he's flipping the spread he said
you the books like the falcons opening
up at five and a half i'm gonna take the
lions by three smart play by you greg
right why'd you take the
money line they're gonna come out and do
this
they're gonna come out and go all the
way like arizona where they just whipped
them around for four quarters there was
no hang around hang around
like you said if they're going to win
it's going to be by a field goal plus
325 everybody's behind dan campbell i
like how we got we got crazy this week
we got off the rails so much so that i
think it's going to work where are the
comments right now before we get out of
here
i got michael ritter he's like wtf greg
ritter believe in the approach brother
believe in the approach and it will get
you there uh i got austin 19 says lions
money lines like that uh
i got
oakland blaze lions play hard
much better than that record okay shout
out to you uh totally larry hall of fame
larry hall of fame says hell yeah great
bet he's rocking with you kenny uh
shout out to you larry
i got one more sorry one more
one more um
kp giant says is both greg and connor an
option why not both yes
bet both
sprinkle it around get some money uh oh
connor the producer just whispered in my
ear i gotta give away a jersey so guess
what i'm back into the comments i'm back
into the comments looking to give away a
jersey and i see
i see
jose hold on hold on i don't know oh the
comments are jumping all right here we
go speko spekko you got a you got a
hoodie today but i'm going to give you a
jersey specco he says he's rocking with
both of our picks shout out to you
specco you are walking away with the
jersey merry merry christmas
that's a big time christmas present as
soon as greg says jersey the comments
start jumping
all right man i think it's about time to
get up on out of here a fun squad ride
week you know the deal when we sign off
throw some money on corduro patterson
boosted the plus 110 in the draftkings
sportsbook app congrats to all the
hoodie winners we are betting they're
going to get back to you don't worry
about it they'll be in your dms thanks
to the lock legends it's antonio squad
ride leader shout out to him ryan
schroeder w trammell p mcquaid 18 and
thank you to all the commenters that
make this show
i'm connor rogers he's the man greg
ivory who doesn't just do it for one day
like santa claus he'll be back next week
giving away everything all over again we
will catch you same time same place next
week
[Music]
you